wir werden auch ein Stück weit und sie
Entscheidung nicht einfach machen
an da oben den zeigen sie es laut und
wütend und aufgebracht
[Musik]
Bürgerversammlung in Kieler 600 Seelen
Zollernalbkreis
[Musik]
noch verteidigen zu müssen 40
geflüchtete sollen in das kleine Dorf
kommen Landrat Günther Martin Pauly
kriegt den ganzen Hass ab volle
Breitseite
irgendwo mal sowas erleben muss das
müssen wir ernst nehmen und das ist
durch die Spitze vom Eisberg
Steine ist Anstoßes das leer stehende
Gasthaus Lamm an der Bundesstraße Wo
seid langem keiner mehr einkehrt was nun
zur Flüchtlingsunterkunft umfunktioniert
werden soll was ist da los woher diese
Wut diese Aggression solch lauthals
gestörte Versammlung angeheizt durch die
AFD das kennt man eigentlich nicht aus
dem grün schwarz regierten
wohlstandsbundesland im Süden
Trigema ist hier zu Hause
Freizeitkleidung made in Germany diese
Stadt ist nicht arm Arbeit gibt es hier
genug der Landrat dachte mal wir
schaffen das heute sagt er längst nicht
mehr was sind sie von Beruf
okay haben Sie Interesse da in dem Beruf
auch hier eine Ausbildung oder das
Praktikum zu machen
zuerst ab nächstes Jahr nächstes Jahr
Ausbildungsplatz oder Arbeit finden das
Thema fast bei allen geflüchteten Karina
kommt aus Kasachstan vielleicht wird sie
auch abgeschoben sie waren mal voller
Elan in Zollernalbkreis pauli zeigt uns
eine Unterkunft mitten im Wohngebiet
ohne dass sich jemand aufregt heute
stellt er fest die Probleme nimmt zu wir
kommen denn den ganzen Anforderungen
nicht mehr nach und dadurch dass es Open
End Darsteller wie ein Fass ohne Boden
ist mir hier in Maschinenraum der Städte
und Gemeinden hatten alle Hände voll zu
tun überhaupt den wenigen Wohnraum noch
kreativ zu finden da klingt dann allen
Ecken und Enden das die Ressourcen sind
mehr als erschöpft die Gemeinden haben
sich jahrelang angestrengt meint der
Landrat aber die Bevölkerung sei
ausgelaugt das notwendige Ehrenamt als
brackelt Sprachkurse mittlerweile
Fehlanzeige gleichzeitig wächst die
Angst vor geflüchteten jungen Männern
auch dort wo nie was vorgefallen ist was
ist ihr Beruf
haben sie eine Berufsausbildung
ich habe in der Türkei in Elektroautos
gearbeitet
Sprache oder Job ohne das wird es für
die drei Männer aus Syrien in
Deutschland ganz schwierig zwei Monate
nach dem Eklat bei der Bürgerversammlung
ist die Stimmung nach wie vor angespannt
aber ganz viele bemühen sich auch um
Sachlichkeit nicht jeder bekommt
Bluthochdruck beim Thema Migration ich
glaube damit beschäftigen wir erst so
ältere Menschen die sowieso ein bisschen
Ausländer
ist wenn die Flüchtlinge dann nach
Killer kommen wenn alle eigentlich
dagegen sind weil dann fühlen sich ja
auch nicht so willkommen
für die Flüchtlinge sie ärgert sich
schon ein bisschen weil sie sich
ungerecht behandelt fühlt im Nachhinein
von Spanien ich bin der deutsche lang
gekommen ich habe nichts bekommen ich
habe gucken wie schaffen ist
und die kommen und die kriegen talis der
Bürgermeister Mitte 30 und parteilos er
steht unter Druck muss die neu
zugewiesenen geflüchteten unterbringen
er will die Wogen glätten kein falsches
Wort sagen das ist natürlich auch in der
Demokratie wichtig dass man
verschiedene natürlich auch Meinungen
dann wahrnimmt und dann aber natürlich
auch in dieser Funktion immer versucht
auch diplomatisch jetzt und konstruktiv
Lösungen zu finden das hier bis 2020
schon einer Bürgermeister war der zu AFD
übergelaufen war darüber spricht da wie
der Licht nicht gern auch nicht über
dessen geistige Hinterlassenschaften gut
in dem Fall schaue ich in die Zukunft
auch mit dieser wundervollen und schönen
Stadt und da dabei möchte ich auch
weiterhin so handhaben
doch selbst hier ist der Rechtsruck
spürbar anders denken der werden
niedergemacht kaum jemand hat den Mut
sich bei der Infoveranstaltung im Juli
pro geflüchtete zu äußern Caroline
leicher schon
auf die Presse das Mitnehmen ja das ist
auch Menschen gibt die heute Abend eine
andere Meinung haben
ein paar Wochen später geht sie zur
öffentlichen Gemeinderatssitzung zum
Thema und sie gibt uns ein Interview
versucht es zumindest wir haben Sie denn
den Abend erlebt also wie war das für
Sie persönlich ja gut zunächst muss man
mal sagen ich habe mich gar nicht zu der
Sache an sich geäußert sondern zu der
Art und Weise der Kommunikation
und ich habe aber im Nachhinein
tatsächlich auch noch viel positive
Rückmeldung bekommen also ich glaube
dass da einfach auch viele Leute waren
die an dem Abend nichts gesagt haben
vielleicht auch überfahren oder
überfordert waren wir unterbrechen mal
ganz kurz wir werden jetzt gefilmt von
den Herrn wollen sie sagen warum sie uns
filmen
und warum sind Sie heute hier
Moment damit ist das Gespräch mit
Caroline leicher leider zu Ende
vielen Dank Nervosität ist hier zu
spüren vor der Stadthalle vor der
Sitzung viele haben Angst vor weiterer
Eskalation ich gehöre nicht zu der
Fraktion die sich damit Berufen hier was
erstellen oder erzwingen wollen aber es
geht mir darum
um das Thema dass eine Ortschaft mit 600
Einwohnern sowas nicht stimmen kann es
müssen andere Gesetze her um diese
Einwanderung etwas zu minimieren bei der
öffentlichen Gemeinderatssitzung kommt
übrigens nicht viel heraus der
Bürgermeister zeigt Verständnis für den
Unmut er appelliert an Berlin setzen sie
endlich die Brille der Realität auf die
Grenzen der gesellschaftlichen Akzeptanz
sind erreicht sie wollen nun versuchen
in Burladingen statt der alten
Gaststätte kleinteilige Lösungen zu
finden also die geflüchteten auf
einzelne Wohnungen zu verteilen die
Kommunen sind überfordert die
Bevölkerung besorgt Landräte auch
Bürgermeisterinnen und Bürgermeister sie
rufen nach Hilfe nach Berlin und auch
nach Brüssel wir erwarten das Leben auch
die Bundesrepublik Deutschland in ihrer
Flüchtlingspolitik im europäischen
Kontext die Situation wieder in den
Griff bekommt es kann nicht sein dass
seine Schieflage entsteht dass wir durch
unsere Sozialleistungen quasi in Magnet
eine so Wirkung entwickeln und 30
Prozent aller Asylbewerber zum Beispiel
im Jahr 2023 in Deutschland landen
obwohl Europa viel viel größer ist wenn
sie nicht anders verteilt werden in
Europa da ist pauli sich sicher dann
werden die lauten noch lauter und immer
mehr